I couldn't tell you what color the shirt
is it's either in the green spectrum or
blue spectrum air mixture both my name
is Charles and I am a strong didn't
technically red-green color blind
sometimes they look similar but if you
have shades of colors that look the same
I might not be able to tell the
difference my name is Patrick vest and
I'm a strong duty I have two daughters
and so you know they like to dress
colorfully and they'll they'll say hey
daddy can I get the pink one or the blue
one or the red one and I'm like trying
to dress them up like I'm I don't know
which is which color blindness affects
mostly men eight percent of the male
population have color blindness and one
in 200 women have color blindness so
patients with normal color vision can
see ten million shades of color whereas
patients with color blindness only see
about a hundred thousand shades of color
people with red-green color blindness
don't have absence of red-green they
just have different shades that they
interpret as rendering so generally when
getting dressed you know I have I have
blue jeans and blue jeans go with
everything well my ex-girlfriend brought
me a pair of red pants for Christmas the
problem is I don't know what they go
with in grade school they have you take
colorblind tests I think in third grade
they had me do it in a private room but
in sixth grade you know we did it
therefore everybody everyone's like you
can't see the three what's wrong with
you my mom said I was gonna be
colorblind as soon as I could understand
it because her dad was and I guess its
genetic so I like to be in like him but
then it got a little bit irritating the
older I got because everybody plays the
game what's this color what's this color
what's this color do not play that game
with colorblind people it's mean it
looks like there are two different blues
here a lighter and a darker this is a
light blue this is a darker blue I'm
gonna assume these that's got to be red
it's a rose so I'm gonna say that's a
red rose this I'm gonna guess it's
purple but it could be like a greenish
color and
this I would call this red but I have a
feeling it might be like a little more
pink than red I'm gonna bet you know I
would know yeah this this total gives me
anxiety actually someone put that away
[Music]
in chroma is a special type of lens that
filters out the light that stimulates
both the red and the green wavelengths
and by eliminating that it allows the
light that stimulates only the red and
only the green so that patients are able
to perceive colors that they've never
seen before
Oh anxious I feel like a little excited
before you could have told me that there
was probably about five colors of all
these grands and now I can see that
there are more than that
it's just it's it's things are just I
feel alright because I'm keeping it
together even though Purple's touches me
right here these two things look the
same to me before that's crazy
this this would have given me problems
before this was clearly red and green
now with two separate colors yeah these
things that were blended together to me
I can now see distinctly different it's
a little overwhelming I don't know how
you can be out in the world with this
much color oh my god really
if I had these like day to day and I
wore them around the house
I might who knows I might see things
that I did not know we're there really
well that's great
so before in my day-to-day life when I
came across something that was color
dependent I would just not do it I would
remove myself or I'd have to lean on
somebody else for help and you know now
that I know that in chroma makes these
kind of glasses I it's nice to know that
I don't have to do that that I can do it
on my own
there was a game they played on the NFL
Network a couple years agos it was bills
and jets and they put one all in green
and one all in red and it drove I don't
know 15 percent of the audience mad
because we couldn't tell the difference
we had to look for the decals on their
helmets so I'm gonna go find that tape
and I'm gonna watch it and see just how
how how cool that's gonna be now bills
and jets played this color rush uniforms
and and everybody looked the same I can
now see green and red I can see them
they're different